[Music]
all right guys here we are downtown los
angeles downtown skid row 6th street
here with mark leyda many of you know
mark from his youtube channel soft white
underbelly mark gets into people's
stories those living on the fringes drug
addicts prostitutes gang members and c
notes
c note who knows the streets really well
down here we're going to walk around
we're going to get an understanding from
mark and ceno
about the homeless and corey corey's
over there on the bike these guys these
guys know skid row as well as anybody
everybody makes a big deal about how
we need to fix homelessness and in l.a
it looks really awful right you have
homeless people living all over the city
even in some really expensive really
nice neighborhoods
but i don't believe the problem is
homelessness at all because if you peel
back the layers you've got
drug addiction behind the homelessness
okay all these people are drug addicts
you have a hard time finding some that
aren't so then then you say oh the
problem is drugs like nancy reagan said
the problem is in drugs so you peel back
another layer and then it's mental
illness behind that okay and then you
can say oh the problem is mental illness
but what causes that so you peel back
another layer and you've got the
childhood trauma the
broken families all that kind of stuff
that people went through if we get shot
at we'll just run
you're well known in two parts what's
the story with this stream
it was way worse than this much worse
yeah for everybody to a certain state
they're all lonely lonely inside lonely
mentally this is the skid row police
station and here's drug addicts right
here it was easy for me had great role
models had great opportunities these
people had none of that a lot of people
are addicted to the streets i'm addicted
to the wildness i've had guns pulled on
my face i've been conned and robbed
every which way you can imagine oh you
want me to get a job and shower and get
dressed and pay taxes and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars trying to fix these
people that are broken and i don't even
know if that'll work it's controversial
but i think about this a lot you have to
change the way you think before you can
make better decisions
[Music]
[Music]
you